so if you look under the IMDB page for
grand Budapest hotel under more like
this not a single movie listed there is
anything like this movie why is that
because no one makes movies like Wes
Anderson the grand Budapest hotel stars
a lot of people and I would literally
spend the next four minutes of this
review listing the cast if I went on to
tell you everyone who's in this movie
but the main star of this movie is
really ray Fiennes the movie opens with
Jude Law and F Murray Abraham sitting
down in the grand Budapest hotel Jude
Law asks this guy why do you look the
way you do why do you look sad I'm
curious about you he learns that this
guy is actually the owner of the grand
budapest hotel and he decides to tell
him his entire story of how that
happened and basically the whole movie
is a flashback where we see him as a
young lobby boy working with ray Fiennes
and how they got to be friends and how
he ended up owning the grand budapest
hotel and everything that comes along
with that this film has surprising
amounts of gratuitous violence outbursts
of vulgarity and heartfelt romance drama
and really really great suspense that
was one of the biggest surprises for me
in this movie this movie has quite a bit
of scenes filled with really awesome and
thrilling tension essentially in this
movie a widowed word dies that Ray finds
character knew very well and she leaves
him a priceless painting and her entire
family is up in arms about that and it
becomes a game of cat and mouse if you
will about where this painting is how
they can find it there's ski chases
there's running chases there suspenseful
intrigue in a museum it's a really
original movie and I loved it ray
Fiennes as this lead character is
absolutely outstanding in this film this
is the best performance I've seen so far
in 2014 he blew my mind and this guy's
been given great performances for
decades I mean Schindler's List came out
in 1993 and this guy is still owning
every moment that he's in frame also
really great is the young version of F
Murray Abraham's character the lobby boy
I'm not sure this actor's name but this
is actually his first movie he did a
really good job in the movie and he had
a lot of stuff to handle there's
incredible supporting work in this movie
but my two favorites are by far Jeff
Goldblum as the executor of the estate
of the older woman and Willem Dafoe
as this guy that sort of paid by the
family to check things out jeff goldblum
I love and it was so great to see him in
an awesome movie again he has a
mesmerizing scene in a museum in this
film that uses light and shadows in such
an incredible way this is the kind of
movie where it's such a fantasy almost
similar to moonrise kingdom where you
don't feel as if you're watching real
events but the characters are so well
realized on the page and so well active
that you actually start to feel as if
this strange fantasy realm exists
somewhere Wes Anderson did a lot of
really interesting things with the way
he framed the camera as well the older
scenes were all done in four by three
full screen in fact the majority of the
movie is in full screen the present-day
scenes had these really beautiful wide
shots look like he was using miniatures
a lot of the time in fact I'm pretty
sure he was and he used a lot of really
great camera tricks like that to sell
the time period in which the scenes took
place what I understand I think is one
of the most original filmmakers working
today and with this film
he completely cements that in my opinion
it's a very funny movie a very heartfelt
movie at times and you really actually
do care about these characters the
performances are top-notch and I would
definitely recommend seeing grand
Budapest hotel if you want to have a
really good time of the theaters and
watch a film that is so different that
you can't really predict where it's
going it's a kind of film where as
you're watching it you remind yourself
oh my gosh I'm watching a good movie
finally a movie where characters feel
like I want to know the next thing
that's going to come out of their mouth
I'm gonna give the grand Budapest hotel
and a definitely check it out it's one
of the best films I've seen so far this
year I hope you guys enjoy and let me
know what you thought of it if you've
already seen it and I apologize I
couldn't have my review up sooner it did
take a while to come to Cleveland a lot
of people have been asking me for that
review guys when it's a very limited
release it will take a little bit longer
to get to my area that's just going to
unfortunately happen I saw it as soon as
I could though so thanks very much guys
and as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck with nice
so guys just to let you know I am still
running my audible promotion and if you
haven't heard about that basically
through audible.com I am able to give
you guys a free audiobook download of
your choice it's basically my gift to
you through them they've been running
this promotion through me for a few
months now they really enjoy my videos
and they wanted to give you guys a free
audio book if you want to
it's basically absolutely no commitment
to you if you would like to download a
free audio book of your choice you can
go to audible.com slash Chris that's
audible.com slash Chris they have a wide
variety of choices that you can download
straight to your phone your tablet your
computer you can listen to it on the go
if you love books like I do I have a lot
of fun with it and basically it's my way
of saying thanks so much guys and here's
something free through me from audible I
hope you guys do check it out and I hope
you guys stick around at audible and
check out some more of their books as
well thanks so much for watching guys
and I hope you check it out that's
audible.com slash Kris